[Musique]
troisième jour ils savent beaucoup de
choses à faire aujourd'hui un peu
compliqué parce que hier sais pas si
vous avez suivi mais j'ai publié une
vidéo sur le honor plaît ça a donné à
peu près une fin dans le montage vers 4
5 heures du mat ce matin dès 8 heures
minimes a donc un peu compliqué excusez
moi pour les petits yeux pour hassan et
compagnie mais ça va quand même le faire
donc aujourd'hui très grosse journée je
vais aller voir oui quand je vois plein
de marques phares york plein de choses
cool donc tout ce que je vous propose de
faire mouche maire titulaire c'est
d'aller faire un tour et puis tout ça
vous êtes une bizarre dans la rue ça
c'est quoi une espèce de distributeurs
peut-être plus en service
je ne sais pas quoi biya
[Musique]
donc là on est avec hervé de wilko alors
oui pour présenter de nouveaux produits
aujourd'hui qui viennent compléter la
gamme vieux de absolument ok on use view
de croo qu'on a rencontré qu'on a vu un
om d'abeilles aussi à barcelone il ya
quelques bons mois et l'a donc de
nouveaux produits qui viennent compléter
tu me les présente un peu mais bien ce
qui est l'adn à quoi il sert tout ça
tout ça quoi en fait on a deux nouveaux
produits la gamme du 2 c'est notre gamme
d'écrans 16-19 deviennent pardon est
donc là on a des nouveaux produits mais
avec un schéma se rappelle une autre qui
est en forme de u sur le vieux de levier
de prix là on a un âge qui en forme de t
bien sûr écrivains du tarn at on se met
à boire debout et on a un bus qui
démarre et donc là on est moins notre ca
légèrement différent alors et surtout
c'est les produits qui viennent
compléter la gamme existante parce que
le judo on était à 199 euros
et puis de quoi 299 euros là on va avoir
des
des performances possibles au niveau de
la patrie notamment qui aurait boosté
parce qu'on passe à 4 millions
avec ouh c'est beaucoup dire qu on a une
vraie journée d'utilisation vraiment
est en revanche revu de booba étaient
des niveaux de prix très agressive parce
que là c'est 59 euros et avec le but de
plus dont nous sommes le but s'en va on
garde un petit peu de suspense comme à
249 euros
249 d'accord alors la différence entre
le go et le plus c'est pour vraiment
synthétiser comprendre la dl propres à
chaque produit alors de manière très
simple le view de plus va avoir une
double caméra d'accord avoir un
verrouillage par empreintes digitales
mais également par reconnaissance
faciale face unlock face unlock est
partiellement et on va avoir sur le
vieux de plus un processeur un peu plus
puissant qu'en que sur le vieux 2 go et
on va avoir 4 giga octet de ram on est
sur un court instant dragon un
snapdragon 450 752 sur le view 2 go il
va pas avoir le verrouillage par
empreinte digitale
on va avoir une simple caméra mais c'est
la même caméra ces caméras sony 12
mégapixels d'accord c'est exactement le
même écran
d'accord le processeur est légèrement
plus léger puisque on est sur un
snapdragon 430 grands thermes de ramon
passe à 3 giga d'accord trois au lieu de
quatre
absolument mais c'est ce qui nous permet
de pouvoir atteindre ce prix de 159
euros
cransac conserve la même qualité d'écran
la même performance au niveau de la
batterie on a quatre mille millions
pairs d'accor et donc c'est vraiment un
produit très très agressif en termes de
prix au niveau design on a une
différence entre les deux produits
c'est exactement le même produit la
seule différence c'est effectivement au
niveau de la caméra
jusque là le flash vous êtes en dessous
puisqu'il ya une double caméra ok alors
que le flat je vais être intégrée dans
d'une zone canard ou absolument croquer
j'avais appuyé on va avoir effectivement
ce ce verrouillage d'empreintes sensas
exactement le même design sur la face et
sur l'arrière
ici tu as un micro additionnel qui est
assez intéressant parce que on va du
coup avoir une réduction du bruit
environnant et on va voir ici un petit
gadget une espèce de petites billes qui
permet quand on pose le smartphone sur
une table d'avoir une meilleure
restitution au niveau du son et donc
perdre une qualité sonore qui est
vraiment optimisé
d'accord ok génial génial
caractéristiques assez drôle sur ces
produits c'est qu'on a doté de la caméra
selphy de fonctionnalités assez
intéressante comme les masques et donc
du coup on va pouvoir avoir le béret ça
pas très bien quel merdier
c'est très sympathique dont étaient un
peu choqués quand même parce que tmg
litote et du coup on va pouvoir avoir
ces masques aussi bien sur la partie
caméra photo mais également une caméra
vidéo la grimace que vont suivre le
personnage hockey autre fonctionnalité
intéressante sur le vu 2 go et sur le
vieux de plus on sait qu effectivement
nos utilisateurs sont des grands fans de
réseaux sociaux donc sur la partie vidéo
je vais pouvoir avoir une fonction qui
va me permettre d'appuyer sur
l'enregistrement les sens on doit
appuyer
je vais avoir une une vidéo très courte
qui valait 2 0 à 15 secondes
et dès que la vidéo jeux l'art est con
je si je devais arrêter avis seconde
j'arrête
oui je vais pouvoir la partager tout de
suite sur mon réseau social préféré
d'accord donc tu es vraiment dans le
créneau temps qui laissait sur les
réseaux sociaux format vidéo très bonne
idée ou croire les partager et avoir une
story d'appui dynamique possible génial
génial donc on est sur des produits
tunisie en termes de taille qui sont
super agressif qui viennent compléter la
gamme view 2 tout à fait ça vient
s'intercaler entre le view deux pros qui
est à 299 way et vieux 2 490 ok je viens
à venir les produits sont disponibles
qu'en dès fin septembre des grès octobre
dans toutes les
ok tu me paraît donc d'un autre produit
également c'est le à riedle harry 2 à
compléter la gamme harry la gamme y
pardon c'est notre gamme un peu entre de
gamme
jusqu'à présent on avait des produits
qui était de 59 à 99 euros
là on a un produit qui est un peu plus
performant qui s'appelle loire et 2 qui
est positionné à 129 euros mais qui
bénéficie de plein de fonctionnalités
notamment du faso knock on va avoir une
batterie qui va être également optimisé
et puis on va avoir toute l'intelligence
artificielle on a développé maintenant
sur nos nouvelles gammes de produits à
savoir une base de données d'image qui
est extrêmement importante et qui va
permettre d'optimiser les qualités des
photos et même sur les view 2 go et vu
de plus absolument à représenter la
région artificielle tout à l'heure c'est
à dire des clichés complètement
améliorer tout à fait sérieux en fait
l'a77 banque d'image va permettre de
reconnaître des lieux va permettre de
reconnaître des conditions de prise de
vue et du coup notamment sur les hommes
les effets boké souvent on a du mal à
faire la différence entre une partie du
corps et de paysages mais c'est ce qu'on
voyait en dit long sur la honda sont
alors on voit quelqu'un qui se prenaient
effectivement en photo et qui avait le
goût de main comme ça la main ici était
flou ça s'était naître et grâce
intelligence artificielle irena lise et
du coup le bout de main tout à fait
nette est certainement bizarre voilà
tout le corps est nette en revanche ça
va être l'arrière plan qui va être
content est complètement flou d'accord
complètement de l'optimisation au niveau
du hdr aussi tout à fait on vraiment
avoir des lumières qui sont complètement
optimisé rien de
saturé enfin j'ai pas là mais on va
avoir un meilleur niveau de contraste on
va avoir effectivement des contrastes
beaucoup plus fort on va avoir des
couleurs qui vont être beaucoup plus
vivant auquel et ça c'est effectivement
c'est grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle et on l'a également sur ce
qu'on appelle le fait ce beauty quand
même sur le visage donc sur les paysages
le visage et des éphèbes ok c'est
vraiment l'intérêt aujourd'hui
d'intelligence artificielle et qu'on
retrouve des 129 euros sur le harry de
génial bon merci à vous merci aux
matières et bientôt mais je vous invite
à regarder tout ça de plus près parce
que c'est vrai que ricco complète sa
gamme c'est super intéressant sur des
produits haut de gamme dans le dans le
dans l'entrée de gamme le père un petit
peu après c'est vraiment cool et est un
produit qui est super jolie avec un dos
le dos avec plusieurs clubs de danse
comme ça commence sur la couleur c'est
super nova supernodes qui va être
disponible aussi bien sur le vieux de
plus que sur le jeu de go et c'est une
très très belle couleur c'est super bon
ok merci à vous merci aurélien des
nouveaux produits de wilko qui sont
franchement super intéressant ce sont
des produits dans l'entrée de gamme ce
sont des produits qui sont destinés plus
tôt à des primo accédants mais néanmoins
je trouve vraiment sympa qu'est ce que
je trouve vraiment très intéressant avec
sept produits bingo c'est que sauf que
oui qu'on va vraiment dans le bon sens
c'est-à-dire toujours renouvelé sa gamme
compléter sa gamme composée des produits
innovants en ajoutant des technologies
actuelles ce qui fait que lorsqu'on a
lorsqu'on est sur un budget pas hyper
élevé on peut quand même bénéficier des
dernières technologies actuelles et ça
franchement c'est vraiment bien
félicitations et quoi je vais vous
montrer le stand le plus
rose
du de l'ifa c'est dans cette école
locale de la cdu rose 2 par concéder
images ici
le magenta
arkema je trahis si pas me planter c'est
juste incroyable
c'est un trou je vois que c'est le
patron de la boîte qui est un très grand
fan de magenta et qui fait autant
magenta un petit peu schizophrénique
comme truc sympa dans un monde un peu
merveilleux du buzz à taper curly mais
bon le standard et non de la gueule un
peu faux willy wonka sais pas si vous
voyez
perspectives de dingue de truquer
complètement incroyable c'est ça la
boîte cvt
salaün les télécoms c'est
donc là on est dans le hall de
conférences de l'ifa directement avec la
conférence qui va commencer de huawei
pour présenter le keirin 980 à la
nouveau socle de huawei le plus haut de
gamme qui va être encore aller encore
plus loin son intelligence artificielle
travailleurs pas mal de choses voilà
donc là l'audience à peu près par la
prépare la voilà c'est cool
donc ceux qui rient 1980 beaucoup pour
parler parce que il va équiper
les gros gros gros smartphone de chez
huawei de chez au nord il ya déjà eu une
annonce qui a été faite par honoré hier
sur le maître jettou qui arrivera je
suppose l'année prochaine peut-être
s'étaler france coûte l'année prochaine
il y aura tous les smartphones haut de
gamme aussi les deux hommes et qui
seront équipés donc on va beaucoup
parler donc vite à faire une seule chose
pour savoir tout ça c'est à vous abonner
et à rester frais
[Musique]
la présentation du king 980 est en cours
franchement super intéressant je trouve
ça vraiment bien que nous dit richard ue
le big boss de huawei c'est que ce
nouveau kirin 980 couplé au gpu turbo va
beaucoup plus vite ils repoussent
beaucoup plus les limites par rapport à
ce qu'on peut retrouver sur un dragon
845 de qualcomm en voir plus loin par
rapport à une puce à 11,2 apple quand
c'est plutôt intéressant et je
quitterais intéressant c'est vraiment de
voir à quel point va se développer
l'artificier derrière avec des grosses
capacités de calcul
c'est un socle et qui est gravé en 7
nanomètres un truc quoi le truc de
monstres un truc de fou furieux qui
promet vraiment d'avoir des supers rendu
sur les smartphones qui vont arriver
cette fin d'année et l'année prochaine
donc on va suivre ça de très près bon
j'ai dû partir parce que là j'ai un
rendez vous d'ici quelque chose comme 3
minutes donc je filme et vous à faire
une chose poursuit toute cette actu
c'est bien évidemment à vous abonner
restez connectés
[Musique]